just the news.com now we are only 56
days away from the all-important midterm
elections and frankly it can't come fast
enough now today we got more horrific
economic numbers inflation was even
higher than expected rising in august
again a 41-year high 8.3 percent food
rent health care electricity all are way
up and are also now at record highs gas
is still more than double what it was
before biden became president despite a
dangerous political gimmick that he has
been implementing implementing to empty
out our strategic petroleum reserves
right before the election how convenient
will flood the market with more energy
more oil so gas prices will seem like
they're going down problem is it's a
major national security risk because now
those reserves are at a 38-year low all
of this after a two-point interest rate
hike from the federal reserve now
another rate hike next week is all but
certain likely another what 75 basis
points which which is massive and that
means the housing market is on the verge
of completely imploding new homes
construction will stop sale of
pre-existing homes will stop home values
will plummet on top of your iras and
your 401ks keep in mind when trump left
office the average fixed rate mortgage
was
2.77 30-year fixed rate mortgage now
under biden it is over six percent and
it is now getting higher so under trump
a 30-year mortgage on a 500 000 house
with a 20 down payment had a monthly
payment of one thousand six hundred and
thirty seven dollars you buy that same
house today it will cost you two
thousand three hundred and sixty nine
bucks a month a seven hundred and thirty
dollar difference now make no mistake
this hurts low-income americans
middle-income americans and especially
those that are on fixed incomes and
simply put joe biden and his fellow
democrats they are now destroying the
american dream for pretty much everyone
attempting to climb the ladder and those
just trying to hold on two-thirds of
americans now they live paycheck to
paycheck and now the market is also
responding they posted the worst single
day since the height of the pandemic in
2020 s p dropped a whopping 4.3 percent
dow jones dropped almost 1300 points the
nasdaq down
632 today but also today during a big
event at the white house joe biden was
celebrating his self-proclaimed economic
achievements now he was actually patting
himself on the back for fixing inflation
and if you think that seems crazy that's
because it is as town hall put a quote
biden celebrates inflation as the
economy crashes and reuters went with
the headline biden is celebrating
inflation reduction act as food rent all
these prices are climbing even the new
york times complaint quote inflation
report dampens biden's attempts to
celebrate the economy on twitter our
friend our colleague katie pavlich put
together a pretty comprehensive timeline
quote march 2021 white house says
inflation isn't happening summer 2021
the white house says inflation is
transitory and it's only a high class
problem august 2022 a month ago biden
kamala harris falsely claiming well we
found out we have zero inflation today
zero and today biden held the
celebration for the inflation reduction
act which makes inflation far worse and
basically you can call it the raise
taxes on the poor middle class and fixed
income americans
act of of 2022 as it turns out it wasn't
much of a celebration for joe who
frankly seems extremely agitated watch
this
the soul of america is vibrant
the future of america is bright
and the promise of america is real it is
real it is real not a joke think about
it think about what you'd think about at
the time
that nobody can doubt
nobody can any longer doubt
that the climate crisis is real
you paid for your social security every
single paycheck from the time you're a
kid you paid for it where's it written
that says america can't lead in
manufacturing where is that written we
just have to remember who we are we are
the united states of america there is
nothing nothing nothing we've ever set
our mind to nothing that we not have not
been able to accomplish
nothing beyond our capacity
joe does better when he's mad doesn't he
anyway he looks like a raving lunatic
and just moments ago when asked about
inflation biden said he wasn't concerned
at all take a look
i think we're gonna be fine are you
worried about the inflation number
though sir no i'm not because we're
talking about one tenth of one percent
and you know
anyway thank you
yeah it was 1.4 when he became president
it's now 8.3 he's either lying or he's
confused and by the way if we use the
methodology that we used uh back in the
1980s it would be a whopping 16 but they
changed the methodology to make it look
better now between his lack of empathy
and his fits of rage and total
forgetfulness and his trouble forming
sentences well joe is getting worse
every single day these policies are an
unmitigated disaster this past week no
exception you decide
this is the extraordinary story
being written today in america by this
administration as i step all over my
coat
good thing my mom's not around
but look
the last guy had this job
well
let me put it this way thank you all of
you the cancer patients survivors
caregivers and don't jump i'm up there
okay
on all uh for all the leaders of science
and medicine this is the united states
khmer for god's sake
this is who we are
you know how much
you know how much i'm going to do with
the deficit this year
two days in a row he remembered the name
of his country good joey good good good
president good job all right almost no
one on either side of the aisle thinks
that joe is fit to serve as president
don't take my word for it listen to
democrat mark kelly who i believe is in
trouble out in arizona he does not
deserve reelection he's a chuck schumer
basically uh democratic socialist uh
watch when asked about joe uh in an
interview take a look
your thoughts on his job
has he done a good job do you think hey
you know i
you know
first of all it's not
my job to give him a report card i would
say you know mixed reviews you know on
certain things
and then when asked if he wants to be
seen with them he stumbled all over
himself translation mark kelly like so
many uh democrats running this year
think joe has done a terrible job and
yet markelly has pretty much rubber
stamped biden's agenda from the very
beginning he does whatever joe biden and
the climate alarmist cult asks them to
do if you live in arizona you should
know this mark kelly is biden he is
chuck schumer we see the same thing with
every democrat running tim ryan mandela
barnes warnock mandela barnes warnock
fetterman
mastro cortez mastro everyone in the
house they all support 100 percent of
biden's radical policies the same
policies that have caused record high
inflation record high gas prices a
disaster at the border a disaster effect
in afghanistan a disaster with law and
order and a disaster in your kids
schools great job joey now the same
policies that more than double the size
of the irs so you can enjoy your annual
audit the same policies that abolished
cash bail defunded the police emptied
out america's prisons making us all less
safe and less secure hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else